what's up you little barbecue cinnamon
biscuits you little caramelized Funyuns
boy you got that junk you ever made love
to a carnival worker well daddy got that
Gravitron so get your tickets step right
up
welcome to this past weekend this past
weekend
you
[Music]
never played me
celebrate live in
[Music]
celebrate misery you know that soon
we're gonna die let's have some fun
while we all die Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to thank Spencer Jacob growl for
sending us that intro music that was
listeners submitted thank you very much
that's celebrate and welcome to this
past weekend I hope everybody's had a
wonderful weekend it is it's Monday May
22nd the 22nd of May May is kind of that
month it's it's not all yet summer some
places are still falling out some places
are in extreme heat a lot of nap time
I don't if it's just me but just tired
is I mean I see people sleeping at bus
stops and people that might be dead but
are hopefully just sleeping I see you
know a lot of just rest ORS and even
birds like the chirping you hear is more
like a [ __ ] like everything is just you
know it's it's I guess it's that it's
that time where things are just kind of
conserving their energy to fend off that
of that hard summer that's coming upon
us you know that dirty heat that fancy
heat that can just press you I mean when
that heat comes it can be violent
I mean heat sometimes the Sun just burns
down a house ever thought about that
sometimes the Sun just burns down a
house Oh a forest fire started why um oh
the Sun did it yeah everybody wants to
talk about you know how science is
amazing and everything but the Sun is
out there sometimes [ __ ] burning down
houses so let's be realistic and
recognize what can go on out there and
recognize that it's still May and that
things can be dangerous you know things
can be dangerous welcome we got a lot of
good stuff on this episode of this past
weekend we don't have a guest we do have
some news we're going to hit Trump was
over there hanging out with the Slim's
the muddies he's in Muslim land we had a
girl got attacked by a sea lion some
students walked out a Notre Dame in the
commencement speech from Vice President
Michael Pence and and what else happened
I don't know
we'll see we'll see what else happened I
got some new dates that I want to drop
on you got some traveling you know I'm
taking this show on the road I will be
in Pittsburgh Nashville Stark County
Illinois New York City Orlando Florida
where that alligator got that child and
where Disney World is at and millions of
people are San Diego and Las Vegas all
before the end of July tickets and info
at Theo von dot-com slash tour so you
can crack into that also Theo von comm
slash store has a new album it's called
musket fire the early years of satire
it's all the early stuff it's stuff that
similar to what's on the Netflix special
and it is you may already have it some
of you guys might have gotten it at a
comedy show at a lot of performance if
that's the case then you don't need it
you know so so anyway this is uh this is
not for you then you won't want doubles
but it's for some people I want to thank
Kara I had a lovely lady come and meet
me at a show and gave me this new mug
this this past weekend mug so I'm happy
to have that and I'm even happier to be
here with you guys I want to give you
guys a hotline number people always
asking me you know what is the hotline
number I don't have it you know I don't
know how to use a phone my grandmother's
ill whatever that number is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
you can call in there ask questions for
basic life suggestions that we can offer
and I also realize you can text that
number I've thought about putting up an
email where people can email but for now
since we still don't have an email you
can text that number if you don't feel
comfortable calling that number again
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and let's hit
let's hit the news man yet Trump was in
I guess he's in Saudi Arabia Iran Trump
is in Iran or Iran people call it
different things that's fine you know I
I'm kind of fascinated with seeing Trump
go anywhere I mean I think Trump
single-handedly seems to keep the news
in business I don't know what they would
talk about like if it weren't for Trump
would there even be any news would those
companies be able to find news you know
there's a lot of distrust with the
Middle East that place can never seem to
to get along it's unfortunate I mean
it's hot as hell it's like I'm surprised
they all just don't stay indoors and
email each other I'm amazed that the
Middle East is even able to fight each
other and have that much anger when it's
so hot out you know I like if I get
angry I prefer to get angry or in the
colder months where even that anger is
kind of creating some self warmth for
you and providing you know a positive
for you as a person you know like I
remember being so cold that I just got
furious so I would feel more comfortable
so I'm amazed the Middle East is able to
you know just keep all the strife up I
mean I wish they would mail some of the
oxycodone problem that we have in
America over there
just to give everybody a little bit of
time to chill out you know who knows
maybe some global warming will bring
some beaches over there into the Middle
East and maybe some some new shoreline
will help everybody relax I think
spending time by the water is usually
very calming I remember actually going
back to last last episode we had people
call in about the first time somebody
touched their crotch you know we had a
man and a woman call in and if you
didn't get to hear that really
fascinating and interesting to me to
hear somebody's experience of the first
time they got that hand you somebody put
their hand on their meat on their
downtown you know on their you know met
it's when you're because at a certain
age your crops really starts to kind of
back in another if you will it's almost
like your crotch doesn't exist and then
shut you hear your crops start to
whisper a little bit whisper this like
you know somebody lucky lucky lucky and
at first you don't but as you get a
little older that it starts to be like
somebody look at somebody looking touch
it touch it touch it you know your
crotch starts to beckon come here come
here come here or bump a bump your
crotch starts to want another it's
almost like a magnet is put into your
body it's almost like a magnet that is
shaped like whatever your crotch parts
are and we had some callers that called
in towards the end of last week's
episode talking about the first time
they got touched in that area
comfortably you know by a person they
trusted and were interested in and one
woman got touched in a refrigerator box
which I thought was interesting and
another fella hooked up with the girl in
the back of a truck which also was very
which I could relate to but I remember I
never got to iterate my time the first
time I you know had really had some gal
touch me down there I was on a boat dock
and that's where a boat if you have a
boat instead of just pulling it right up
by the shore and getting off of it like
you're some kind of pilgrim people build
a little dock a piece of wood a stretch
of wood from the land out into the water
kind of meets the boat halfway it's
almost like a handshake like a wooden
handshake that goes out from the land
and you know kind of welcomes the boat
welcomes the boat back from from the
water but anyhow this gal gave me a hand
job and ejaculatory experience out there
by the on this boat dock and it was
nighttime or duck you know it's just
starting to get dark I guess and I
started you know spraying out at the end
you know and that's nature and some
people think that's gross and whatever
and well guess what if you think that's
gross then you must think that you're
gross because you got here because of
ejaculation do you realize that that all
most of us are is tall ejaculate
that's all we are we are ejaculation
that has gone astray if anything at best
you know and and so if you're grossed
out by that then you need to come to
terms with that I think you know I hate
to pass judgment but that is you got to
get that together because if someone's
talking about semen or seed and that's
what you're made out of
it's your root level then that's
alarming if you can't deal with that I
feel like you know that's how you
started you know you weren't made out of
you know of sugar and flour this you're
not a recipe you know you are seed an
egg so anyhow I remember getting
ejaculated out into the water off this
boat dock and all these fish came and
started you know uh uh just devouring
all of you know what I'd created with my
body my Jack ulation you know and I hate
to now him now I'm feeling kind of I've
said it enough they started devouring up
my seed and I remember that gave me
nightmares from I don't even know how
long months at least that that you know
that there were you know I have these
dreams that I was you know like a round
fish and I was erect and it was just
alarming and I get alarmed near fish in
near water and my I would feel just
nervous whenever I would swim in the
river anything extremely nervous scared
of snakes and then also scared of that
these fish that had gotten this you know
dessert out of my body we're going to
come back and we're going to find me or
knew me you know as if like because you
know what dogs sometimes adults can
remember your smell they have dogs some
dogs work for the police department and
they are you know primetime sniffers and
when they can you know remember you just
through their nose and I was worried
that fish would be able to remember me
and come back and get me but anyhow what
we're talking about Trump is in the
Middle East
you know I just think III think it's
funny watching Trump do anything you
know he's a fish he is a fish out of
water you know he wasn't a politician he
got into it you know he got he won the
election and I've never been a big fan
of politics I don't think any of these
politics I don't think this system for
me is set up to really I don't think
it's helping as much as we wish it could
and also I don't know if it ever will or
can you don't know what a lot of our
complaints are sometimes like all we can
do is do our best for ourselves you know
I mean I just need to continually worry
about me and about keeping my side of my
life clean you know because I still have
problems before I can even really when I
think about it even though I get mad
about things politically the bottom line
is I'm not my politics in my own life
and hearts aren't even straight so to
then expect the whole system to be great
when I'm not as organized and as
functioning and efficient as I could be
it's a big ask it's a big ask you know
but I'm worried less about politics
since I don't you know I don't have that
much faith in the system that I'm
worried more about about news and where
do we get real news these days you know
people you know I'm not going to go into
it but I just I find that the news these
days is all advertising it's all I look
at it all of that advertising it's all
an opinion more than it is the facts so
where do I get my news these days I
trust my heart my instincts and that's
it really you know and I try to just
stay on the slow trail of of making
myself better on the politics that are
inside of me because those are hitting
really close to home aren't they so why
don't we try and maybe you know we can
try to spend our time you know gestating
over those rather than the big-picture
ones what else in the news Notre Dame
students walked out they had a
commencement speech or a fancy talk you
can call it
Mike Pence who is the vice president
who's you know this year everybody's in
an uproar about or seems to be a lot of
you walked out they didn't want to
listen to Mike Pence they don't like his
views I don't know that much of my about
Mike Pence I've never been that into
vice presidents I don't know anybody
that has you know except for like some
creepy substitute teacher when I was in
junior high it was like you know I had
like a maybe he might have had like a
tattoo of Michael Dukakis on his back or
something but um but yeah these students
walked out yeah it's the right you know
that's cool I would have stayed I think
just because he missed the experience
you know like how did they all they know
from Mike Pence's what they've seen on
the Internet or what they've you know
read like is that is that super
trustworthy for me it's not I would have
listened to the guy you know you can
yeah then you can be like oh I didn't
like this that he said I didn't like
this that he said but you didn't even
get that you know you didn't even stay
to get even if you got one thing out of
his speech that inspired you that's more
than most college student get in there
four or five years of college you know
for me so I probably would have stayed
and listened I was on a cruise one time
as a student I was working on work-study
on a thing called semester at sea and we
went to Cuba this is in 2002 and Fidel
Castro came and spoke to us or we went
and listened to him I'm sorry he didn't
come onto the ship it was a cruise it's
a really great program it's called
semester at sea there's there's like
about 1,200 students and it goes around
the globe on a ship on a cruise ship so
you get to experience it's like a buffet
of planet Earth you get to go to
different countries and and have some
experiences and one of my experiences
was to visit Cuba and Fidel Castro came
and spoke now Fidel is you know I think
it's pretty factual that he's murdered
people he's a dictator
he's you know I know for a fact I walked
into some bookstores in Cuba and there
their history books started at when
Fidel and Che came into existence there
before that you couldn't even find any
history so they had almost they said
this is when our time began and you
couldn't find any history before that so
obviously they were dictators right but
I still sat and listened to the guy like
I wanted to catch a vibe from him I
wanted to get some kind of idea what did
I think you know did I feel like the
whole time he was talking that he was
full of [ __ ]
did I think that he you know could I see
how he could you know manipulate the the
the the human language so that he was
able to control people like I just
wanted to see I wanted to get a vibe so
I stayed and listened man you know I
just wanted to see and maybe he did
would have addressed those allegations
he didn't you know he didn't talk about
being a dictator he talked about just
how well Cuba was doing in their
relationships with America and a lot of
it seemed really you know can and
whatever but it was a great experience
you know and I stayed for the experience
you know I stayed for that experience
because if I walk out yeah I'm not a
huge Fidel Castro fan but but if I walk
out I lose the chance to listen you know
and also as a man and as a dark artist
you know I got the darkness in me
sometimes and there's something
old-school
about some of these dictators that
they're the last of a kind you know like
you know there's like I don't think it's
wrong for at some point someone to think
like I want to rule a colony or I want
to you know be a king you know if I were
in the medieval times I would you know I
would have ruled the land or I would
have been a king or I would have you
know had a bunch of unicorns or you know
I would have had all the wild ponies and
the maidens and all that and this dude
did that you know like say what you want
like yeah I'm sure you know maybe he was
a piece of [ __ ]
but he was also a ruler and a dictator
and I mean that's pretty [ __ ]
gangster when you think about it to just
have whatever you want kill whoever it's
like Game of Thrones it's like you know
people loved watching Game of Thrones
and part of it is because we would like
to imagine ourselves in these roles of
being a dictator of being a ruler you
know even just to imagine yourself there
that they're in that role for a bit
that's interesting you know so I wanted
to stay because I got to hear a dictator
speak for three hours and and it was
interesting it was interesting you know
but the Notre Dame kids they didn't want
that they wanted to walk out and to me
it's a little bit disrespectful but I
guess if that's you know if you feel
that strongly and you know that much
about Mike pants and you're already
against him then I guess I can
understand you know because I also like
to be efficient and I don't like to
waste my time so but that's something
went on man that's something else
happened in the news what else
British Columbia a sea lion attacked an
asian girl now if you're not familiar
with where British Columbia is then
you're just like me it is I believe it's
part of Canada it's like on the far east
coast of Canada and I could be wrong
that's fine
all we need is one plate tectonic shift
and I might be right so you never know
dude all we ever think about that all we
need is one plate tectonic shift and
everything could change bro next thing
you know it's Popeil news Sacramento huh
you ever thought about that have you
have you considered that bro that it
could be the district of Mississippi the
Washington DC em the Washington District
of Mississippi with one big plate
tectonic shift you know you could be
living in Pensacola Pennsylvania all it
takes bro one time for Mother Nature to
move her bowels and everything's going
to change so think about that
huh what else man oh so this a sea lion
attacked a girl an asian girl and I
don't know if they pick favorites or
what they prefer but this sea lion
there's a video on it on youtubes on the
internet and they have a they have a
little girl and her family they're Asian
and they are standing around and they
look nice you know and I did I have
never met an Asian that didn't look nice
they all look like they fit perfectly
into their clothes like they come in
exact sizes you know like they fit a
small they fit a lot that fit a medium
they they other like white people I know
for sure it's like Oh what I'm between
the unella and em you know like I got to
buy a shirt and dry it twice and then
not you know and then never dry it again
to fit but Asians I mean right into a
shirt it's like they never it's almost
like they knew the shirt in a past life
and now they're meeting back up they
always seem to fit very well into their
clothing but anyhow this sea lion the
family's playing with it it's in the
water in some type of water I'm guessing
off of British Columbia and it kind of
jumps up by the girl and it that family
thinks it's cute well then the girl sits
off with her back facing it's as off of
a dock you know right I mean keeping
docs in the lineup here this is off of a
dock the girl sits and the sea line
jumps grabs the back of her shirt pulls
her into the water bro and then her
she's a grandfather that's Asian and he
jumps in very quickly and gets in and
gets her and gets her and gets right out
remarkable quickness - for that man for
rescuing her I thought but then a lot of
Asians I see very docile extremely
well-put-together I mean it's almost
just well-organized bodies and minds I
feel like they're kind of a Tesla of
humanity for me that's what I think but
um but
my thing is why are you playing why was
this family playing with a [ __ ] sea
lion okay first of all it's called a sea
lion yeah not a sea puppy not to see
Kitty not a sea horse they have those
but this is a sea lion dude both things
the sea all right extremely dangerous
you know owns 70% of earth fact maybe
more kills pirates kills bacteria
saltwater what else dude kill surfers
has sharks living in it that's what the
sea is and then a lion bro lion yeah not
a kitty a lion usually ever spent time
around a lion yeah well yeah well we
probably haven't heard from if you have
because they [ __ ] people up dude a line
doesn't play bro a lion will lick your
eyeballs out of your [ __ ] face holes
okay
so that's what a lion does so sea lion
no thanks
I'm out you know that's like somebody
saying hey why don't you have one of
these why don't you have one of these uh
Grim Reaper Viper snakes you know once
you get one of these Grim Reaper Viper
snakes buddy you'll be fine no I won't
probably and that's the kind of [ __ ]
that pisses me off when you know you
have prideful Asians who are fired up
and they just start thinking that they
have it all and the sea lion attacks but
you don't [ __ ] with sea lions dude you
don't [ __ ] with the sea lions dude knock
knock who's there
somebody who's not [ __ ] with sea
lions that - okay I've been attacked
before yes I've been attacked by cats
been attacked by dogs
but an attack by a group of black men a
couple times or not men but you know
kids that were in my grade but they were
also older than me
who've been in my grade before some of
them I've been attacked
you know I got hit by a car too when I
was a child a nice silver car so I've
been through some things just letting
you guys know that
what else man what other news let's
crack into a little more news for you
guys the NBA playoffs to me it's boring
sorry it looks like it's coming down to
Golden State versus Cleveland which we
all knew about six months ago so just
the simple fact that everybody knew it
and now it's happening just take some of
the excitement out of it you know Golden
State this time they're going to be a
rematch of the finals and this time
Golden State has one more all-star
player Kevin Durant I think it's it's
almost overwhelming how some of these
teams can just pile on the all-stars and
then they win the championship that was
one nice thing about seeing LeBron win
last year even though they were pretty
stacked it didn't seem like they were as
stacked as Golden State it's going to be
interesting to this year when they
rematch and LeBron doesn't have a lot of
new players and Golden State does I I'm
a little bit sick of the NBA you know I
think that the players have gotten too
fast I think that the level of talent is
too high I would like to see a larger
court or higher rims and I'd like to see
some diversity you know I'd like to see
more diversity in the NBA to many
African American players I want to see
more white players more Viette more
Asian more poly Latino players where
they at okay how about some good Mexican
players you telling me that you don't
want to see Guillermo Gomez fire off a
50-foot three-pointer wearing khaki
pants like he does every day on his
lunch break in Los Angeles every day
drive by a playground you'll see it
Mexican guys love basketball I'd love to
see more represented in the NBA I also
want to see an Asian coach you know head
coach an Asian coach we've had Erik
Spoelstra yeah Erik's Palestra yes I I
get it but I want full I want to know I
want everybody to know that he's Asian I
don't want to coach where some people
are like um I think that guy is maybe
Indian no I want to coach where
everybody knows he's Asian I just like
to see some more diversity NBA
help me out help me out sorry I'm
sipping on my on whatever I'm drinking
there all right guys what else we're
going to crack into some questions I
want to thank everybody for hitting the
basic life suggestions the hotline and
again that number nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three you know I
didn't have a ton that happened this
past weekend you know I just didn't
really have a lot of stuff I'll give you
a sensual update personally I'm still
struggling it's really kind of flared up
struggling with the masturbation and the
masturbatory actions and activity and
pornography's kind of snuck back into my
lifestyle and I'm not happy about it so
it's a challenge man it is a challenge
and for those of you watching porn
comfortably jerk away daddy bear you
know or freaking being out you know
sugar tits being out but for those of
you struggling with it you know just
keep trying
we keep applying ourselves that's what I
try to do is just know when I'm messing
up or just know what I want to do better
and I got to start asking my higher
power for some help because I'm starting
to think that maybe I'm not capable of
solving the issue or getting it to a
comfortable place for me on my on my own
so we'll see we'll see about that but
let's get into a few callers here let's
go from just Catherine hey Theo this is
Megan from Phoenix Megan
onward I'm just calling in because I was
had a lot on my mind lately just
generally about how I'm doing where I'm
going and it all kind of came down it
comes down to the question of how do I
feel most successful and I was calling
the kind of ask you the same question
how do you measure and value success we
got some uncertainty in the desert it
sounds like with Megan let's go now I
have three jobs I'm working my ass off
to do what I want to do and it seems to
be going in
fairly the right direction but I'm
constantly stuck thinking maybe I should
do more maybe there I'm not doing the
right thing unlike my brother is getting
married my cousin just had a baby my mom
just beat cancer like these are things
that I value is successful and that what
I'm doing I don't really see as much so
I was just honestly curious about how
you value success Wow you know I'll say
this immediately can you notice how
women are so good at just organizing
their thoughts concise like she kind of
got it all out most of the calls from
dudes we're like oh hey bud this is um
you know it's just interesting how we're
different different like that
and that's not everybody that's just
Megan and and then all of us men thanks
for calling Megan I appreciate it
it sounds like you know you you're
measuring success you want to feel
successful
you weren't really comparing material
things so that's great
you know I mean it's great that you're
not in that plane on that plane or on
that tant on that tangent or something I
don't know what it's called but it's
something where it's not it's great
where you're not comparing yourself to
others materially because that just it
never ends bro there's like a guy in
Persia who's like you know eating you
know drinking gold milkshakes out of
silver vaginas and that guy wins he wins
so materially you can't you know you
it's hard but it's not like you're
comparing yourself to people emotionally
you know or like in things that matter
it sounds like maybe your soul is a
little low you know your soul might be
low and one of the ways you can fill
that up is by doing things for others
you know because you mentioned things
like you know your brother's heaven
your brother is having a baby or your
cousin's having a baby your brother
don't you graduate it's something your
brother did something your mother just
beat cancer you know those are all
things that are you know family and
orient or family-focused or you know
things that are important things that
are meaningful so it sounds like you're
looking for something meaningful
and in ways you can find that are really
just going to be by helping others you
know but in the meantime if you don't
have that ability you can you know say
if you don't have a family of your own
you didn't mention that you can still be
a good daughter you know you can still
be a good new aunt to the baby you can
you know work on being the best one of
those that you can be and if you're
doing that then you really are doing
your part maybe you're just not
recognizing some of the things you are
doing you know I mean you said that
you're working three jobs but you're
also it sounds like have been working
three jobs in the sole section you know
you have a mother that beat cancer and
it sounds like you care about her so you
were you were probably there for her you
have a new baby coming into the family
and it sounded like you know um you at
least know your cousin who's having a
baby and and your brother I can't
remember what's going on with him let me
go back and listen right now I have
three jobs I'm constantly stuck thinking
maybe I should do more maybe there I'm
not doing the right thing maybe sorry
and like my brother is getting married
your brothers getting married yes you
have the brother getting married and I
bet yeah maybe you're feeling lonesome
Aaron if you're married but you know you
can be just be the best sister you can
be you know be the best bridesmaid or
whatever however you're involved so it
sounds like you know those are three
jobs that you're doing as well so maybe
you just need to recognize that uh that
your soul is probably a little more
fuller than you think it is that you are
pretty successful even when it comes to
like you know things that matter not
just work and how do I measure success I
haven't always done it well you know I
grew up having a lot less than people I
grew up feeling less than and unloved
and so I really put a lot of those
things as things that made me feel
successful
you know just wanting people to like me
no matter what needing to be popular
because I just I felt like no one cared
when I was young so you know I put some
those things ahead that I shouldn't have
but now I'm trying to fill myself up in
the soul section you know so maybe I'll
see you in the soul section at at Sam's
Club would it be great that a soul
section you know you're like I'm just
going to get a couple bags of these uh
uplifting flakes yeah so I just got to
keep working I got to keep working at it
I think I'll feel successful then you
know when I'm a loving caring person
that is is continuing to be that each
day even when I feel some days like I
don't want to be so I think that would
be my definition of success and helping
others you know does those are days when
I feel the best but don't be too hard on
yourself because it sounds like just
from your voice maybe it's judgmental
but it sounds like that's you're a
pretty good person all right let's take
another call here we go heyo
this is Chuck you from Odessa Texas
we got Chuckie from dirty Odessa Texas
I've been down there to Edessa and I saw
one of the dirtiest animals I've ever
seen I don't know what kind of animal it
was it had a lot of dirt on it
onward Chucky and I was called because I
wanted to get some advice from you okay
it was spurred because of a listener
Michael won the bang the chick
finger bang the chick on the back of his
94 pickup yep I remember Michael called
last week we added some people call
about corrupt Crutzen tots crutching
tops last week touch'n Christ onward but
anyway so I would want your advice on
how to get over the first girl that gave
me a [ __ ] mmm I've been chasing the
dragon ever since I've gotten [ __ ]
from multiple girls but it seems like
she's the one that tops them all
unfortunately she's moved on and she's
married which is fine I don't have any
feelings for her but the [ __ ] part is
where I'm having trouble so they're
having trouble getting over Oh like I
said
still chasing that dragon and she talked
call Wow
okay so you had that great [ __ ] that
beautiful suck is sucked from that girl
and she's gone and married now and
you're trying to get past that well for
one have you thought about the fact that
I mean your penis might have less
feeling in it these days you know I
might sound crazy but when I was young
brother I mean my feeling could mean my
penis could my penis could hear a bird
you know it's 70 yards away like what is
that a nightingale I mean my penis was
erect for whatever it was basically a
watch dog you know and my penis had a
you know a big plan every time but now
my penis dude I got I mean there could
be a you know a cart full of you know
fresh cooter could spill over next to
the bed not even know if my penis would
get up and be interested so some of it
could be you're just not getting the
same feeling in your penis as you get
older I know that that's an issue for a
lot of men so don't feel too bad about
that
but I think one thing you can do is tell
girls what you want you know I think you
can tell girls what you want because you
if you're just chasing that special
[ __ ] and you might never get that
that's you know you don't and the times
were different who knows what you were
doing back then you may have been poor
[ __ ] always feel better when you're
poor so I think you know you might be
chasing like an invisible dragon that's
what you might be chasing you know so
you might just want to tell a girl that
you like or that you love you fall in
love with what you like and what feels
really good and kind of coach her you
know because I think women are open to
that you know don't be mean they'll be
violent you know don't get all russian
on her but just be you know helpful and
concerning you know but some girls are
better at it than others man I had a
girl one time gave the softest [ __ ]
ever too soft I mean like she just had a
bunch of downy dryer sheets in her mouth
she barely even would touch my penis
with her mouth like she was a mime like
she was just a mime just sucking [ __ ]
you know and and I didn't like that man
it's like it's not Jango like you can
you know put a little pressure on it but
I let her go and sometimes I wish I had
you know she was a great girl she just
gave those you know just the way to soft
[ __ ] like a baby was sleeping right
next to my dick like that I didn't like
that very much you know so yeah I think
the best thing to do is to find a girl
that you like and in the tell her what
you really enjoy I think that could help
outside of that you can keep hunting bro
you know a lot of good girls out there
that are giving them you know some are
crazy though I mean one girl pulled on
my balls so hard I mean I swear to God I
have a kid with a long neck first kid I
have going to have a damn longest neck
you've ever seen and still from that
girl Miranda was her name and that was
near Poughkeepsie if anybody's ever been
out there I think near Poughkeepsie
anyhow I was going to take one more call
but you know what I'm going to do I got
to thank you call from one of you guys
and I just want to play that on my way
out tonight I'll just show some
gratitude and I want to thank you guys
for for listening and be a part of this
past weekend I'm going to try to do a
special on we've had a lot of guys
calling in talking about manhood and
what that means and I know I've been
saying I'll get to it and I will it's
just been hectic it's just been hectic
there's got a lot going on and I'm
feeling blessed and fortunate and better
this week even better than it was last
week so I appreciate your support and on
the way out let's let's listen to this
call we got to thank you and this is
from Chris and Groveland some of you
guys are calling Lee thank yous and um
and I never play them and I hope this
doesn't offend Chris but I appreciate it
you know I really I really really do so
you guys be well take care of yourselves
and after this I'm just going to close
out you know we got a good week ahead of
us I think you know let's believe that
and if you're having trouble hit the
hotline man and I'll try to help out as
much as I can all right man you guys be
swell all right and this is a thank you
from Chris in Groveland we're going to
check that out now you guys have a good
week man be good to yourselves and and
you know why dude because you probably
deserve it i'ma try
mature
my best man and I'm gonna pray for me
about that masturbation but I'm trying
to lay off that masty and stay confident
and stay steadfast and keep my feelings
tight inside myself tight tight tight
tight here we go
it was up Theo my name is Chris and
friend turned me on to you about a month
and a half ago and then it sounds crazy
man but your sense of humor speaks to me
and I I was like dying of thirst for a
comedian or somebody a podcast
personality and I can really relate to
and I know this sounds corny as hell bro
but it's alright bro
okay to sound corny man you know I'm I
mean [ __ ] you don't think I feel corny a
lot of times saying all the [ __ ] I say
bruh but um but you know appreciate :
dude I appreciate you sharing your
thoughts man onward you're really
refreshing you've kind of inspired me to
start writing we have similar
personalities and similar sense of
humors and I just want to say man I
really appreciate what you're doing and
keep up the good work and I was listen
to one of your podcasts and you would
give an advice somebody about how try to
find happiness throughout so outside of
your work and you mentioned something
about doing stand-up comedy that
sometimes two days a week you don't feel
like you're on the right path and I just
want I just want to continue to
encourage you and let you know me you
are on the right path
you're the best comedian I've heard in a
long time and I really appreciate you
putting your it's outside then your
honesty man because it's really
refreshing and it helps out a lot of
people more than you'll ever know I
appreciate Theo take it easy bro well
man thank you dude I appreciate you man
I just want to say you're welcome you
know and I'm not playing that to get any
you know self joy you know but I wanted
to play that for you guys just because I
get I get some calls like that
people just saying thanks you know
wanting to share their gratitude and I
think that that's important you know I
think it's important there's some times
when I don't you know I want to do
something and I just
don't do it because I feel weird or
embarrassed or I feel like I'm gonna be
ashamed you know something that's good
some of this good things you know we're
just telling somebody thank you or just
sharing someone how I feel you know so I
appreciate that Chris man I hope I don't
put you on the spot too much and and
you're welcome dude and uh and you know
we're trying you know we're just trying
to share our ship bro you know because
we all got a lot of [ __ ] Doug you know
ma'am damn daddy's diaper is full you
feel me but you're welcome in and I'm
gonna take us out again man with a
little bit of celebrate from Spencer
Jacob Spencer Jacob growl who reached
out and sent in his music we got some
great calls we'll hit them hopefully
maybe later in the week but if not next
week man thank you guys for listening
and I do want to tell you also that you
can you can subscribe online if you're
if you're watching the the podcasts are
listening online subscribe or put a
rating or review all that kind of stuff
helps out man you know we're going to
try to get some sponsors to out to help
alleviate some of the costs so you guys
be good man bless y'all take care
alright and on our way out celebrate
you
[Music]
never played me
never came in
[Music]
a little bit of dark song the beat is
uplifting
[Music]
magic Blind Melon a little bit it's
really good man we all die
[Music]
all right you guys be good man I'm out
of here take care have a great week hit
the hotline if you need me
thank you guys let your friends know and
thank you so much for the love and
support bye